عامل النظافه صاحب واقعه محل الكشري هكذا
عرف عالميا للشاب محمد الذي تعاطف معه
المصريون بعد طرده من احد اشهر محلات
الكشري في القاهره بسبب ملابسه لكن محمد
ليس مثل الايتام عادي في مصر يظهر ويخفت
بعد يومين او ثلاثه ايام فمن دون انتشار
قصته منذ اكثر من اسبوعين يرفض محمد
مغادره منصات التواصل الاجتماعي ويابا الى
ان يكون نجما مره يتناول العشاء مع الفنان
احمد العوضي ومره نشاهده يقدم واجب العزاء
في المحامي فريد الديب وتنتشر شائعات عن
خطبته لمذيعه او تعاقده على فيلم سينمائي
اخيرا يبدو انه اكتشف موهبته في الغناء
عصام شعبولا نجل الفنانه الشعبي الراحل
شعبان عبد الرحيم اعلن عبد الرحمن حسابي
على فيسبوك
يجمعه محمد الجدع وهو اسم شهرته الجديد
وهو اليوم ضيفنا للحديث هذا المشروع
المنتظر
اقوى غينيا ان شاء الله كلمات النجم اسلام
خليل والحان عبد الله وغناء محمد وحسون ان
شاء الله باذن الله
مع محمد عن عمل مشترك واغنيه دويتو مشتركه
بينكم حدثنا بالاول عن هذا الاعلان
وقعدنا نتكلم
[موسيقى]
همم اصل هو انا بصراحه ربنا لقيته يعني
شفت الشهره بتاعت النجم
مشهور زي سوره النجم بس انا مش عارف يبقى
نجم في ايه
فقلت انا اجربه انا اللي اجربه في الغنى
جربته لقيته ينفع يغني اا
يعني على قده في الموضوع بس هيجي منه يعني
الموضوع هيعدي وهيجنني
كانه تحول تتعاون معه او تعمل معه اغنيه
حتى تلحق او تستفيد بالترانس
حضرتك
كل الناس انا مش محتاج محمد عشان اطلع
تريند عليه انا البس وابقى شكله ابويا كده
اطلع ترنجات انا ابن شعبان عبد الرحيم واي
وقت هالبس هدوم الجزمه والحزام والبنطلون
والساعتين والحاجات هابقى ترند في ساعتها
انا مش محتاجه اطلع التريند على محمد انا
محتاج اما لقيت محمد لقيته غلبان قلت
سبحان الله يعني همم الدرجه دي كلها لو
بتتعمل بفلوس كان زمانك كلفت 20 مليون
جنيه
الدقه بتاعه محمد دي لو بتعمل فلوس كانت
رقم كبير قوي
في ناس كثير قوي بتوع المهرجانات دول
مشهورين قوي وما بيعرفوش يغنون
يمكن يضرب وينجح ما تضمنيش
زي بقيه الموجودين في السوق والله العظيم
الاصوات وحش قوي قوي
اسمها ااا
ازاز واجري
وغنوه الثانيه اسمها احنا اولاد تسعه
كلنا اولاد تسعه
احنا اولاد تسعه دي انا بغنيها ومحمد
هيبقى واقف موت
ممم ممم دي اللي بتغني محمد فيها
اللي انا هاقوله دي بتاعه سانكيو اللي
محمد اغاني فيها موت
[موسيقى]